so I guess we're all assembled here to
witness the glory that this era I mean
welcome
well you lose know why you're here
because I don't know how many people
here actually have heard of a dong
that's positive um the language is
pretty sure that's the one I meant thank
you for clarifying how many people here
have actually programs in odda
respectable so not for LP flirts
everything they'll be completely new
then but there are probably some people
here oh definitely interested in
learning more details about era so guess
what this starts first of all I mean
what the hell am I to tell you that ad
is wonderful
well that's me race by computers through
I mean a crew up on a forum so yet
aren't yet animals and for computers
they're so in books for this pretty much
Rohtak for outfits I taught myself to
program talking as a child basically
like well my second language I learned
was qbasic and underdose so that happens
during the 90s I kind of displayed along
with lots of languages and eventually
well C++ was this thing I'd heard about
which was like this major professional
language I'm going to play around with
Java when it was new and nobody cared
about it but it's all those problems
about everything fissile basic faith
right wrong way that a bit it was it was
just a basic come on PSP JavaScript
before it was cool and then it's still
not cool and yes C++ like I mean I've
been playing around the scripting
language yes and she like I want to do
desktop programming a server programming
and all the cool stuff other cool kids
do not just this bit of websites
HTML CSS
you know before CSS became useful C++
it's like I read about it was like I'm
going to learn it and I went to the
bookstore and the culture books only the
first one was like simple plus in ten
minutes or something one of those books
that's a lie it's more like ten minutes
but the the second book I cut was the
C++ programming language appearance
toast hope I hope I pronounced that
someone's correctly and my apologies and
that book pretty much taught me
everything I really need to know about
programming because yarn like this is a
style guide it's a reference for Super
Plus is a tutorial is everything for
Super Plus in one and the still simple
plus 98 so the old stuff I mean
everything here here at the conference
all about the cool Stassi of plus 11 is
already this old fashioned thing I
learned C++ in 98 and always happy with
it so oh yeah that probably is a few
books so - about - about C++ C even so
first book doesn't really count or
something about game development on
androids nobody cares what kind of
element Android if writing unity and she
just probably small platforms now second
book was on C++ multi-threading but
there's an interesting subject
especially because you got so many
frameworks and interfaces you know pitch
rats
it doesn't love P threads it's good fun
with that and of course you feel first
laughs and threats and all this stuff
really interesting time then this book
which is published this year is about
embedded C++ I don't know how many
people here have ever thought about
doing and better developments in with
C++ and okay that's pretty much what my
research also showed me like because
there is at this point at least a moment
of publication there was one other book
currently imprints on Amazon about
embedded C++ so there are now two books
on a better C++ in prints
so there you go that's my contribution
to the simple class community and learnt
a lot
let's do a disclaimer because like I
said it's not added to toriel and not
here to tell you how to write a DAC out
and more to tell you about why it's a
cool language and why I think that's you
may want to actually try it because I
like it and well my opinion isn't law
yet it will be soon maybe party right
now I just want to show the one there's
I mean just like Gators with us love
kittens
I didn't harm any kittens but other is
like kittens I mean they've got those
tiny little claws and they grow up and
it gets sharper and they start hurting
you but they're still fluffy and cute I
think it's kind of symbolic for other so
yeah coming back to when me just meeting
C++ it's just it is the first time like
a real language because Jaffa was
nothing I mean javis you have to stall
this runtime and there's I don't know
JavaScript just runs in browsers PHP
cool if you've read websites which run
faster than CGI script I guess it's
about its and you can use it for
everything
like I said embedded is what I started
doing with it more recently even just
abusing the Arduino core as little bits
to rewrite it to be a pure C++ framework
for embedded developments some stuff
like that
but you know it's Super Plus is what's
the first thing that does everything you
can you can even read surface in its
I've wrote a servlet implementation
called the surf thread but with a C and
an F so it's almost the same thing
surfers and badatz desktop mobile C++
does everything so it's this is one
language you learn and then you can stop
learning languages that's kind of what
the corner I was in so really just
awesome language lofty two bits first
compiler was Borland
back in the 90s like late 90s the
variant many free or goods to change for
Windows
so borland released a free comment line
only compiler tool chain and it was like
I got this right with that and at some
point I guess fits of studio became an
option with the free version and yet GCC
became actually usable and functional
and available on Windows this is really
useful so 2000 was still a rough time
for C++ just getting started
yeah this it's not just they can come
run superperson
on everything it's also that's the
motive power taken properties of it
that's like you only want to write it
like it see I mean sometimes I think I'm
kind of filled OSI developer in terms of
how I write C++ I like a low-level stuff
I don't mind pointers I mean they're my
friends they don't hurt me Matz and you
can go high you can look in low as
purchased in C++ Levin you've got more
high level interfaces and it's just just
this it's worm language but it's also
this big grizzly bear it's I mean the
debugging tools you have I mean for
grinds is my bestest friends ever
I mean without for grinds I would not be
able to do my job or I would be but I
would have debates for many more hours
because some multi-threading bugs and
issues you can find it in civil postcode
or seek out or anything around there
it's not fun but you can pick your own
safety level that's it's definitely
because many of the matter the criticism
leave it against C++ is about
well it's unsafe you use pointers route
pointers and she gets always stack
overflows and whatnots
I mean have heard some from those people
we like the where thread stuff they
complain a lot about that that's not
true I mean since
steeple plus 98 you can actually already
use reference counting and just don't
touch the heap directly you can do it so
it's okay but
like there are some parts about C++ very
like it is like using C back in the
1970s I was a life back then but if I
had been a life back in the 70s I would
be thinking in the 90s with C++ this is
like using C back then because it's you
can see it's there is a lot of stuff
that is back in the 70s it was cool and
acceptable and we still have it I mean
why a preprocessor it's it's own macro
language made to language which dismiss
ads all of those those bits and parts
it's messy I mean there's a reason why
Buren Strauss Roop recommends to never
ever ever touch macros on this fourth at
gunpoint and then maybe even refuse it
merging header files into into source
files that's seriously woo here hasn't
had trouble with just figuring out the
right link in order for header files in
a source file that you just like okay
now it doesn't compile a cat with errors
you shuffle a few header files around a
Sun is like it works
that's it makes me really sad sometimes
just figuring it out and this should not
be necessary and linking I mean at the
point where I have those does really
nice falcon pelts and the compiler is
like all happy with its and you get and
the linker is like yo I will just put it
together and then you figure out that
right it has the symbols there and there
but they have to be linked in this order
because if it's it's there and it has
not seen that the symbols fit sorry over
there it's like yeah they know that's
and the key here cattle in error the
whole syntax you get with civil pass and
see to chain linkers is just amazing you
know where the whole link static link a
link whole there are so many options a
couple of projects really taught me a
lot of those flex I'd never knew about
and it really useful and it works in the
ends but you feel so
and clean at the ends like it should but
it should be this is nice little make
file with a bit one one sense destroyed
in there sources there in there object
files throw it into the linker and it
compels and it links and is done now you
have this whole argument it has to go
into the linker of like the whole
paragraph so that's not my favorite kind
of hobby so the syntax
I mean see syntax I mean if the reason
where C style syntax is really popular
because it's easy to rates a some might
argue that is not what they usually
fizzle basic fence or worse but once you
start adding templates to it it gets
bitten conflate a conflict that's still
readable just don't try to debug it too
much especially back then and without
actually having gdb with a nice by the
script that's make a sed map into
something that's actually readable so
it's a bit it's a bit tricky there and
when you start adding more symbols to it
and like I mean my absolute favorite is
like having Const you know like I think
the Const function Const what does it
actually mean what does it do you can
read up on it there are many Stack
Overflow polls where lots of people are
totally confused about what certain
keywords do because lots of keywords and
like for a newcomer you like order all
these keywords I'm not using those I'm
staying away from them and using just
this part I understand because I'm
comfortable with that and only if you
really want to invest time and effort
into it then you can learn how it works
and if get it if you look it up again
the next day because it's not intuitive
or maybe I've got bad memory
I mean for now and yeah this is
something which is very personal I mean
STL headers like a sed string that's
that's pretty much my pet peeve with C++
because there's all like all the new
headers being added and so like shiny
and new and
but what about adding a few nice methods
to the portal string to make certain
operations easier like I mean if you
look at Titan for example it's shrink
functionality is pretty amazing it is
stuff built in it also the the fella
interfaces me I know you've got the file
system in in 17 good edits 0 + 17
standard code the file system that which
is kind of already usable I've used it
but it's still a bit of pain to actually
really use it and you have to use the
newer compilers otherwise it still in
the experimental namespace and things
like that which is not fun so it's it's
messy and so I feel at least low-level
part and there are the foundation there
and really the workhorse is like the
simple string are being neglected I
don't like that and well don't get me
started about boost because I mean okay
how many people here actually like using
boosts in projects using I guess that's
pretty much I mean anyone will start to
use SEO and it's like at how many new
space is nested in space is deep before
you actually hits it like something like
ipv4 you have to go to every I mean I'm
not against namespaces but the abuse
namespace is get in many boost libraries
that's insane and this whole thing about
use one header only library of boost and
suddenly pulling in like 90% of boost
I'm also not into that and that's boost
is the only source of future and C++
features that also make me a bit nervous
I guess doesn't mean the networking
interface will be this issue I have
experience with and I'm not looking
forward to it I mean I hope they make
some improvement and hoping it's not
least namespaces get a bits fixed
because that was not fun
I hope to clean up the interface at
least but it makes me bits like why I
don't get it so okay what do I really
want from language because I mean I've
been whining about syphilis now and this
I've not felt any rotten fruit hitting
me yet so that's good not offended
anyone
I hope my expectation in language is
just well designed which is pretty broad
but this at least it is just coherent
design that you really feel like there
have been some people some expert have
been looking at it they've about some
design requirements they put some from
the head get together what you feel this
fits together this is really meant to be
this thing and it's not something that
was just drawn up on the back of a
napkin used napkin and then someone took
it and played around with it right it's
actually it should be designed and the
syntax clear and readable so just you
look at it you can just read it as
though it's it's like English there's
not always not all books are easy to
read in English but internal yes and of
course easy to build any buck which is
kind of comes back on my issues with
actually making more complicated project
with lots of libraries linking with C++
it's coming this absolute nightmare and
even I mean using just looking at the
symbols in sight instead archive files
into object files to figure out which
one is actually there and whether it
actually got exported yeah I don't want
that and of course I mean it's less
point but it's also important efficient
and safe like the one thing I really
like is that the language makes it clear
when something is going to be not
efficient and not safe as you like okay
you can go there but here be dragons you
get this bit of hint so I've been doing
some VHDL on the site not sure how many
people actually do fpga development here
but yeah
it's not fancy I also like hardware and
that guy was like some this red that oh
it's VHDL syntax that this derives from
the ADA syntax the Department of Defense
in the United States they were like we
must have VHDL and just base it on this
language you already use lots so I
learned about 800 upon it and was like
doesn't hurt to talk with that person
right so or language so reading about
what ADA does what the difference are
just the whole summary about your memory
safety just how it actually treats
things like pointers because they're
ours you can use safe pointers in C++
but the still kind of cumbersome and
it's it still feels a bit like yeah
stuff - a lot of work concise I mean ADA
one of the design calls was just like
you must have a few different concepts
in the languages possible to make it
easy to use and understand so that fits
well and a module system because in ADA
you got packages like and you've got get
the specification which says okay this
packet says that and that's just done
and it gets you don't even need the
whole the rest of the of the packets
it's there the compiler does only needs
it way at the ends because the
specification contains all of the
information you need and it just gets
used compare it with the actual users in
the source is compiling so it's it
doesn't have a preprocessor which is
just merges text like whatever it
doesn't care and with already you throw
something in there because it's like
it's all there I just built up this
table I look at it I've got everything
and there's no include order because you
don't you're not including you're just
telling the compiler hey here's the
stuff I want you to compile into object
files go ahead
and strong typing that's I mean it's not
something that you would have really
thought about a civil first because I
mean see is not really strongly types
and this until people see 11 C++ has
relatively strong typing as in as well
at least yell at you often about a at
least at least warn you haters probably
not a good idea like comparing unsigned
and signed integers which you get all
the time and you just ignore it because
hey it will never go wrong
so it was interested then of course
you're like okay you look back on your
current relationship for the other
language which you thought you would
share the rest of your life with and you
like discuss complicated because I might
just going to write everything in a des
from now on and we're just going to be
one of those out of a finger shoeless
just everything is ah de I just delete
all CP plus code after I convert
everything and know it's us that's a bit
too much so I think it's just how can I
actually use it to like they both have
their strings have two weaknesses like
C++ I mean if you program with the since
2000 so that's a long time you get to
know the language and I'm not scared of
it it's not I've got no reason to stop
using C++ let's put it that way
it's I still love C++ I just guessed
it's yeah I still care about it but it
opens obviously new things so but he
didn't do it's like when you start a new
project how do you choose which language
you're going to use well right now I've
decided that for hobby projects I would
just use both like I write it's usually
first and C++ because I'm most familiar
with that's I get it working
then I ported to to add on and I tried
to get it working just as well and
that's kind of a learning experience
that that's how I just can directly
contrast ok those concepts which I mean
I'm pretty low level developer this
wrote a book about embedded C++ so low
level stuff and C++ doesn't scare me low
level stuff in a day is what interests
me and so that's why the projects I
wrote it's a pretty low level sart's
that's actually one I've got to show a
bit more of that's actually this just
this project here so it's on my github
you have got a nice windows 98 theme on
there it's it's free you can also use it
I just like it it's more readable yeah
it's it's a command line argument parser
which you would also think that hey
aren't there already like 50 million
command-line argument parses out there
for C++ yes and no I mean there is none
in the in the language itself in the STL
there is nothing like that I mean unless
you call arc fiag see a command line
argument partial but it technically is
there's more operating system doing hard
work for you so and I looked at a few
options and it was like it's got this
massive this convoluted like a thousand
lines of templated code and what hell is
even doing anything that even implements
its own DSL and cool and stuff but I
just want something that's just text
these options i configured in my app and
compares it with what comes in VRC
ography so i what something's 106 lines
of C++ code I mean if it was really
proud of it so did the c-loc thing like
yeah that's showing off that's it's
pretty simple to use and it support all
the flag types short optional option and
value string there's probably more stuff
that you could add to it but that's just
feel free to open a ticket we get up
other version is just well it's not 100%
port yet because I just have it as a
single package you cannot have instances
of it but how many times you need more
than one command-line argument parser in
the application
so I thought of a acceptable compromise
you just have it slightly simplify it
you can see the it's the test
application it's if you just look at
this and you look down at the simple
fast version it's not that different I
mean in terms of general look the
interesting thing is very actually start
looking at the code for it this is the
other specification so the header file
for people who need a little bit of help
as you can see those are things which
may or may not make sense
so they mean defining your own type of
Records is a struct so for example it's
lots of top stuff Maps pretty much
directly then I've got here the this is
the header file for the simplest version
it's just maybe slightly easy to
recognize it's the same same functions
same methods I should say class methods
but it's yeah it just bit less stuff
let's really see that's already bits of
it Adam is that for example in functions
you really have to have to specify the
it's kind of like objective-c for those
who know that's yeah actually specify
first the name of the argument and then
you have to specify the type then you
specify the direction that you can F
it'll soon as an input or out or
catheters in out so I specify what it
does and interesting note there is also
that you don't get to use so you don't
get to decide whether it's the fail
you're trying to pass is too large for
requesters or the stack the compiler
decides it's looks at it it knows the
runt and knows it does it all for you so
I don't worry about that it will be fine
so you will not blow up the stack
because it will not allow you to blow up
out the stack so developing now stack
overflow
a procedure has no return cell you it's
a strict distinction in odda
is that when you procedure is something
that does something but it doesn't
return anything is like it's like a
fourth function or for ignited a class
method in C++ we have this strict
distinction if you ever have a function
they get something like this where we
have to specify what it returns it's
actually something that I mean other
comes the first anodised in 83 so it's a
lot of things like that's from back then
I mean like this vegetable plus
officially it's class methods or class
yeah it's a class matter it's officially
what you call it I believe and are those
real distinction nobody really cares
about it very call it a function or
procedure or methods it's all guys use
interchangeably but there is a
difference and in adding you've got this
difference between a function and a
procedure so you look at the front and
you immediately know it's going to
return something or nots
Hartree aren't guaranteed oh that's I'm
glad you asked the the thing about
eighty is that the type system in Ada is
so that you don't get any predefined
types like I mean you don't mean there
are some integers predefined for your
own pleasure in the the standard library
data library but normally it is first
specify an integer is just like arraigns
like I want this to go from zero to
whatever or minus something to whatever
strings are similar most rings are just
are actually just limited in size so I
specify upon the string to be this this
large except when you use an unbound
string that is one exception if you
don't know how large is going to be then
you can use an unbound string and I just
to put out I guess because I mean it's
absolutely I think if you were to do a
any kind of code review with real added
developers which I'm not yet they would
look at something like this and it would
be like you could change that there's
going to be a bounce string you're going
to figure out how much you need air but
limit is and she going to say this hard
limit and that's it because they not
never come different out of memory for
one it's fine it's already in there
covered in arc failure listen to
answering it dis return so whether it
actually has as found the flag so if it
doesn't find the flag this one would be
changed it's similar to reference in C++
yeah that's a matter of taste I mean a
C++ I'm like I did the same thing in the
C++ version
I actually people to hate me for that
but I return a bool I just return a bool
because I call me a C developer but I'm
just used to that this the return value
is like did it work they did not work
and the value is sent passed by
reference that's something i've also
nice thing is you can return multiple
failures that way and things like that
and it's less complicated I'm not sure
is more efficient but be interesting to
benchmark that maybe so that's
these variables before calling uh-huh
it's not a production code that's my I
really assist someone fixed back in in
the coach or this felt like an issue
with one one type of comment line
argument which was not going to work
with it's and it's got fixed so it
looked better but haven't had time yet
to fully test it and break it which is a
fun part and that's also why I've really
interested in actually taking the zip
code and seeing how easy to break it as
compared to the ADA version that's
definitely interested in that so we're
gonna look at the actual look at looking
at headers and specifications but yeah I
mean just a quick glance at like this is
normal syntax I like commenting I really
like commenting its it just makes me
happy so that's the brief stroll through
the C++ version and then you look at the
the body of the other version just to
give a quick impression so same comments
it's nice as you're typing you can see
there are no curly brackets anywhere
because it's I think some of the Pascal
and Fortran developers here may feel a
sense of nostalgia there it's it's
similar to that it's this is meant to be
this readable you don't have any symbols
it's just all like you just read
something just like when you start to
loop it's just for in something you loop
and also important is that something
actually and something you say here and
loop explicitly you don't have any
dangling and you like dislike closing
curly brackets what did you close for
this end there nobody knows in this way
the compiler can actually check like oh
you did actually close it or I forgot to
close in statement somewhere else before
that so
just like your function or procedure
also ends like that
this you have to actually specify the
name of it so it s contacts with the
compiler can use to actually fill a day
that you were not just forgetting
something because you must forget stuff
and this is the kind of stuff that the
compiler can just look at and be like
you forgot that so yeah that's a starts
name for our PC is an remote procedure
call library which I wrote in C++ I've
imported it yet there's a lot of
networking stuff and multi-threading
multi-threading is integrated into a DES
since 1983 so it gets all the current
stuff is already there natively in era
it's integral part of the language so
there is no like before a C++ 11
something could not do that or you have
to use pipettes whatever you use Adam
you can use concurrency it's it's just
there so that's what I'm looking forward
to porting that and well I mean I'm
currently freelancing and that work jobs
and there are always clients they come
to you or your boss comes to you and has
like here this takeoff requirement is
like most we've written that language
I've even written in stuff in JavaScript
a few years which is not fun but you
learn from it so use whatever is
required I mean try to coerce the
clients to use something more sensible
but if it's if everything fails then
there you go that's what he use and for
my own projects best of both worlds just
use both and learn from it and maybe
improve the simple plus standards this
would be nice
turning table plus into a DES oh and
talking about learning ah de there's
always this as if hada it says massively
complicated language you never going to
learn it it's it's only people with like
20 years of industry experience have
some idea of what it actually can do and
can actually really use it but it
doesn't really jive with this whole
comes
and out of the seven as few concepts and
simple and concise syntax as possible so
the second points the core concepts they
there are not really hard it just
different I mean it's a different syntax
if you used to see people style same
text and you look at the other and
you're like well and we're looking at
Fortran now it's okay I mean just for me
it was transitioning from C++ to Adam I
love more tools just the first time just
writing them make file yes I'm one of
those make felt people write to pay
hands you notepad plus plus orphan
writing to make file for vertical piling
my first ADA program and just not make
doing the whole thing for me and this it
realizing just how simple this is going
to be is this provided you don't have to
worry about includes order and things
like that and I love more chills I mean
I totally get for simple plus 20 it's
likely going to have some more chills
support in there I mean it's only like
39 40 years after a dot but
congratulations there are some
improvements I guess but no preprocessor
as well it's just you just have to
language you don't have to languages or
three languages in the case of adding
templates templates as well so you have
to reference the right syntax every five
seconds
but that's why I've got references for
and when it works it's just you don't
have great crashes and stuff like that
even though I do pretty dirty stuff in
the next to the parsing with using to
data structure side by side and actually
F and one is just a reference to file
use in the other you know the useful
stuff that works just fine in added
fewer problems with that and in my C++
version different I first implement so
concept like that so points go to add it
there and
I really just like it is the feeling you
gets it's not this dirty disgusted
feeling after you've done something in
C++ and you like especially some linking
routines and feeling like okay it works
now but I don't feel feel okay with that
it's pretty much I think the summary of
my professional C++ career at this point
cool stuff there but awesome lots of
moments very like C++ is also patient
but more in the like just just do
something write codes kind of kind of
version or depending on this communities
you're in like someone is like hey
there's a new version in the new
standards which I use and you should not
learn too new to use the old stuff gosh
you have to use the new stuff there's
only the new stuff you will never be
stuck with the GCC for two - I was stuck
with GCC four to two with the dinkum
their standard library without C++ 11
support or anything resembling it Thank
You Q and X learning the old concept in
C++ is totally phalates but it's just
this whole tug of war between old and
new and yeah okay that's more the
disgruntled with C++ version but with
ADA you just have to read the
documentation I guess that's so read the
documentation stay disciplined not to
skip through it don't just copy code
from Stack Overflow I mean the will not
be a lot of ad code on Stack Overflow
anyway but that's beside the points funk
a lot of people in free notes are seen
in the ADA channel who are really cool
people and they helped me out with lots
of stuff you can add some questions they
are really patient just like ADA they're
just they love to explain because
someone is using their language so great
community really just love it and the
compiler as well because everything is
so explicit it just if the compiler says
is wrong it's wrong and you made a made
a mistake
except for the funnest thing was
probably I back in with the referencing
what stats might still have be my faults
and Monsieur so they said it first not
my fault but so I also like the the
source code its ends up looking clean
because you're not adding lots of
symbols and where it's things in
brackets everywhere it's just like
you're writing a sentence with some
numbers in there so it's it's easier to
read and I just like similar to free HDL
I mean I don't see how many people
actually have programmed in VHDL okay
very look good oh the difference between
looking at open source very look out and
the difference between looking at open
source VHDL code that's kind of like
what you see with with Ada and C++ as
well because lots of C and C++ code is I
mean everybody is their own formatting
and it ends up being like yeah okay
hard to read lots of things everywhere
and with Ada EF fewer options to just
write whatever and the formatting says
roughly the same so because one thing
which I didn't point out in the code
earlier but it's kind of similar to the
old stale seed that you have to declare
all the variables at the beginning of a
procedure or function so everything
stays nice in one place you don't just
mix stuff and that's really healthy
readability
so of course if you're so few different
concepts that's why I always know why it
works it's not just that you like well I
mean like this week I was playing around
with some lip field C code and I just
tried to compel sample and was like yeah
they're some win main issue I couldn't
find the symbol blah blah okay well does
it work wide is it trying to search for
that and it was something about
somewhere else isn't it's also finding
that and the solution is undef main
works so if that main indefinite
everything is fine again and that's
that's as far as I got on that issue and
that's it's a commonly used see library
so I could research it I could figure
out by its doing the thing but not worth
it and so you and with Ada it's doesn't
have that problem in Smuts and super
strong typing that's actually with the
earlier talk about concepts in C++ 2010
reminded me of that because one thing
ADA has is that you cannot like if you
the type is that my end is integral the
USA my end is the type integral it is
type def essentially then you cannot
assign later very variable of type my
ends to a variable of type integer or
vice versa
because there are different types I mean
obviously you type theft it so it's a
different type so you can it's you say
you have a string you defined a nice
little string on both the string or AB
on the string and you say I make type
ISBN out of it or a street name or
whatever you can never ever just assign
it to a random string for a goal or a
phase first it's always going to be that
type it's going to be a street name it's
going to be an ISBN number in string
format and nothing else
ever so there is no confusion it's
always that's going to be that type so
that's really the explicit type there is
nothing
implicit in odda it's not going to cast
anything for you it's not going to
convert anything for you your big
developer you can do it yourself you
know what you're doing
I've just uh first just a simple cast
would suffice there you would have to
tell the so basically it looks like a
seat type cast you could say
interstellar hey I know it's this it's
actually defends this type but I know
internally it's that type and then you
can just use this enormous ring but you
have to explicitly cast it or at least
instruct the compiler that's you know
what you're doing you know that there's
not that type so I'm pretty sure if we
yell at that let's look at I mean if
it's if it's actually a string in sight
then it would let you do it but if it's
incompatible it was still yell at you
because it's like you're just saying
okay it's compatible but it's a
different type it's also the distinction
there so some may have noticed study the
a Ducote force arts the port is slightly
more from post and the a c++ couple
dozen more lines and nets of code in 176
instead of 136 big deal but it's this
more tighten up front to save time later
because you really explicit with this
indicating what you're doing and why
you're doing it and it should be easy to
read so that's just for readability
they have run times they feel a phone
because a des comes pre equipped with a
wrong time which is configurable very
which can actually catch things like
buffer overruns and all the the things
that if you do something funny with
unbounded string and you have that
enabled in the runtime it's enabled by
default i believe then it will destroy
an exception and unlike with civil plus
exceptions other exceptions are
lightweights that mean they have been
used since the 1980s so running on those
military hardware since
as an integral feature so they're like
wait they're essential part of the of
the runtime and you can catch pretty
much anything that happens aside from
the hardware catching on fire which you
can still catch but you can do anything
about that so there are multiple safety
levels there would have to look up this
ones but it's basically like the memory
it is also with you don't get heap
corruption because you don't get it
touched the heap or the free storage
because it's actually an atom as this
default storage boom which you can
create by excess type for it's just it's
also used and so you can also create
your own storage pools with different
for different access types give them
different access levels and so basically
segment the heap in different sections
but you'll never and that's directly
don't allow pointers the runtime will
actually handle it for you so the access
to to the heap do this always like you
can also specify the access level
specify whether it's read with rights or
read-only things like that so they're
quite a few options there and some may
have heard of spark the spark ADA
dialect it's the extra safe feature of
the cessation of ADA which is actually
what was used for programming things
like the Ariana four in five rockets and
if your necks and things like that with
even more strict spark was edits
contracts so our contract based
programming among other things with this
since control based programming is part
of a DES 2012 now so spark is becoming
its basic like what's that is going to
become apparently the contract based
programming is a thing which is really
nice for safety because you know exactly
what's going to come back from from a
function there are no surprises because
surprise of that contour based
programming helps with things like
static analysis is to prevent things
from going wrong before they happen
the if you really want to know
everything about the working group that
actually worked on defining the
requirements for a de it's actually
disqualified every single language it
existed back in the nineteen seventies
early 80s the Steelman language
requirements document is the one which
actually compiled for the Department of
Defense and back in 1978 ul is their the
working group assisted out of experts
from all around the world so including
Dykstra may have heard it name sometimes
and everybody could consult it
essentially this in national
international experts and they all just
worked together on this one documents
and use that as the perfect language to
replace the hundreds of domain-specific
languages with the Department of Defense
was using at a time for embedded
projects so it was pretty big thing to
live up to like you have this four
hundred fifty languages or more they add
big done and you won't have this one
language that's binds them all and
that's they made their own language they
just outsource it to four different
companies the contract had done say hey
make this awesome language using disk
and 100 plus documents have set of
requirements and they went to work at
the end two of the contractors got
eliminated how fit room just okay not
good enough next to continue it the ends
are the results they kind of merged both
sides and they named it Adam what came
out of deaths so I think was the Green
Team would actually want so it's not a
hobby project it's not a hobby language
it's I mean I really like C++ but I also
have to admit that it was basically him
back in the late 70s just hacking
classes on top of C it's it's not it's
not that so I have to admit that there
is bit of a slight the difference in
terms of scope there and when language
was designed and it explains a lot
and kind of can't forget that of course
I mean the Ariane 5 rocket on the left
the 15 jet fighter the overrun era
so I mean you don't easily get into this
program if you don't become just become
a developer on those programs because
security clearance and all that because
of the extreme safety requirements I
mean the contract contact base
programming the the runtime safety
levels so because the whole language was
designed from the ground up to be as
safe as possible
that's no matter which fault occurs you
can catch it you can handle it ok aside
from the rocket exploding or something I
mean this is shame but because you're
before you even compile it the first
time we compile it you can already catch
like 75 and 90 percent of our common
mistakes which developers make like oh I
forgot to close that one curly bracket
there and well the compiler still
accepted it and it still went into
production somehow and there it exploded
literally that's something with that is
designed to prevent and it's a language
it having three minutes to programs for
these kind of harder like that that
you're often not allowed to do any
memory allocations yes should never run
out of memory so just ought to have any
special facilities to have very tight
control over your body and we did the
stickers or future limited so if you do
and know enough if you call enough
functions one after the other you will
blow your stack but that's what's going
to prevent that that's pretty much this
a heart error for the operating system
to handle sadly but there are the heap
based at least so there are the free
storage that is being handled by the
better storage pools so you can actually
set the limits access levels everything
on that
kinds of things can have you can set
several different kinds of limits for
different things
yes we have had different access types
and you say okay this point turn to soon
name like that but access type has these
extra levels for this storage spoon this
block of memory can be used for this
access type with these these X's levels
and with these sorry you can access you
can assign rights I should over the user
account or something to those access
types and when you use the access type
you can not do anything that is not
explicitly allowed
so that's prevents on a lot of issues
like you don't get anything like well
for interest or ie it is reading into
some random random memory or using a
null pointer doesn't happen and I mean
you can always run out of resources
that's subtly that's at some but you
would discuss it I mean stare look and
noon they will just used to tell you a
nice like okay X requests tonight
there's no more memory so you should
theoretically just have something to
handle that's I mean I'm okay no 99% of
all developers never check whether
actually the allocation if it worked I
mean would checks for the new actually
succeeded and you we just all assume
that there is infinite amount of memory
but our ways to handle that I mean if if
an in C++ you can handle that nobody
does it but our ways this is ad is more
explicit about it so
I think a large part is just because
it's it was language designed by the
Department of Defense it was no snow the
cool hip language like all the other
ones I mean for turns really strong in
the scientific community it still is
I had Jeff was this this really big
language being promoted by a by Sun was
going to be the next big thing is going
to completely kill C++ and everything
because would run on chips and yeah do
sell on arm which is kind of that so I
think it's mostly an image problem
people see it as this this thing used
from military things is this Department
of Defense language and it's scary and
it's big and when you hear those myths
about how it's complicated the under the
sart's protects I haven't benchmarked it
yet but definitely with with the name
for our PCC library wins I want to get a
sport it I will do a lot of benchmarking
on that so I've ready benchmark the C++
version of there's lots to optimize it
and that will be I would definitely
benchmarking both to compare that
because yeah that's yeah there you go
thank you so as well skip because there
you had more context while typing the
codes so it knows more things so there
the compiler the optimizer it's it has
more information to work with and also
because if you have a fewer concepts for
women concepts so there are fewer s
cases and things like that is far
simpler to optimize for so yep
and also really like the logo they have
for odda
that's so I'll try to wrap my head
around kind of with categorical language
Otto fits in is that is it basically a
procedural language that just uh more
strongly type see it's it's also multi
periodic and it does object-oriented it
has I did have procedure and procedural
knots really is more immersive oriented
towards slightly procedural
object-oriented and a contract based
programming I think those are I look at
that I'm sorry
that's absolutely right yeah
right yeah and also uh generic
programming so kind of like templating
is also in a DES no it is actually
designed by experts second
that's what not surprised me actually
that's my glove ii was pretty in-depth
things you see it's just a single f on
that just immediate just handle its
price understand it but i could be wrong
something i think I'll be using
exceptions more with seven export of
noon for pc then i can probably answer
the question better so any more
questions then i think oh it was
requirement until summer haul veteran
90's there since droplet requirement of
everything must be either a snow some
languages are also accepted like c++ d
f-35 you know that's well running
projects as its for have written in c++
but this is subset of course like this
one safe certified fella dated subsets
it's a specific tool chain probably it
will probably c++ 98 i guess but so yeah
it's a popularity that has been dropping
but this kind of coming back again and
I think it's a cool language and I was I
would really like to see the community
it's this really nice community for
Alfred I just welcome more people into
it because I really like the community
and the language so yes and most recent
first I thought I was a 2012 and 140 of
2005 so it's they've still got regular
updates and I mean ADA will not go away
because like I showed them in Ariana
there are new rockets and Boeing and
Airbus and I mean every single satellite
pretty much in orbit right now they use
a DES because I mean you're not going to
flash for updates on the satellite in
orbit so there you just want to have
like wit spark and this pure safety and
security and weld testers because you're
not gonna take any chances
you're not going to I mean some people
have Cube sets up there with no T as I
believe but okay looking forward to it
I have to buy new reference books but
I'm looking forward to it okay thank you
yeah so I think we're done with
questions and and thank you very much
for being here
[Applause]